today I'm going to show you how to set
up an HTTP or HTTPS load balancer first
navigate to networking now navigate to
load balancing now click start
configuration in the HTTP HTTPS load
balancing section fill in the name of
your load balancer you can use lowercase
letters numbers and hyphens click
back-end configuration to configure
where your incoming traffic will be
redirected from the drop down menu you
can select an existing back-end service
or you can create a new back-end service
now enter the name for your back-end
service from the back-end section select
an instance group finally select a
health check from the drop down at the
bottom click host and path rules from
the left panel the first row determines
where any traffic not explicitly with a
host and path rule will be sent click
add host and path rule to add a second
row now fill it in click front-end
configuration to configure the protocol
IP address port and certificate if
necessary finally click the create
button to create your load balancer